Not An inspirational speaker.
I've never lost a limb on a
mountainside,
metaphorically or otherwise,
and I'm certainly not here to give
career advice because,
well,
I've never really had what most would
consider a job.
However,
I have had large groups of people
listening to what I say for quite a few
years now and it's given me an inflated
sense of self importance.
So I will now at the ripe old age of
37.9
bestow upon you nine life lessons.
One,
you don't have to have a dream.
Americans on talent shows always talk
about their dreams.
Fine.
If you have something you've always
wanted to do,
dreamed of,
like in your heart,
go for it.
After all,
it's something to do with your time
chasing a dream.
And if it's a big enough one,
it'll take you most of your life to
achieve.
So by the time you get to it and are
staring into the abyss of the
meaninglessness of your achievement,
you'll be almost dead.
So it won't matter.
Okay?
I never really had one of those dreams
and so I advocate passionate dedication
to the pursuit of short term goals.
Be Micro ambitious.
Put your head down and work with pride
on whatever is in front of you.
You never know where you might end up.
Just be aware.
The next worthy pursuit will probably
appear in your periphery,
which is why you should be careful of
longterm dreams.
If you focus too far in front of you,
you won't see the shiny thing out the
corner of your eye.
Two,
don't seek happiness.
Happiness is like an orgasm.
If you think about it too much,
it goes away.
Okay?
Keep
busy and aim to make someone else happy
and you might find you get some as a
side effect.
We didn't evolve to be constantly
content.
Contented homo erectus got eaten before
passing on their genes.
Three,
remember,
it's all luck.
You are lucky to be here.
You are incalculably.
Incalculably lucky to be born.
Understanding that you can't truly take
credit for your successes nor truly
blame others for their failures will
humble you and make you more
compassionate.
Empathy is intuitive,
but is also something you can work on
intellectually.
Four,
exercise.
I'm sorry,
you pasty Pale smoking philosophy grads
actually in your eyebrows into a
cartesian curve.
As you watch the human movement mob
winding their way through the miniature
traffic cones of their existence,
you are wrong and they are right.
Well,
you're half right.
You think therefore you are,
but also you jog,
therefore you sleep.
Therefore you're not overwhelmed by
existential angst.
You can't be Kant and you don't want to
be play a sport,
do yoga,
pump iron,
run,
whatever,
but take care of your body.
You're going to need it.
Most of you mob are going to live to
nearly a hundred and even the poorest of
you will achieve a level of wealth that
most humans throughout history could not
have dreamed of and this long luxurious
life ahead of you is going to make you
depressed.
Five,
be hard on your opinions.
A famous bon mot asserts that opinions
are like assholes and that everyone has
one.
There is great wisdom in this,
but I would add that opinions differ
significantly from assholes in that
yours should be constantly and
thoroughly examined.
Okay?
We must think critically and not just
about the ideas of others.
Be Hard on your beliefs.
Take them out onto the veranda and hit
them with a cricket bat.
Be intellectually rigorous.
Identify your biases,
your prejudices,
your privileges.
Most of society's arguments are kept
alive by a failure to acknowledge
nuance.
We tend to generate false dichotomies
and then try to argue one point using
two entirely different sets of
assumptions like two tennis players
trying to win a match by hitting
beautifully executed shots from either
end of separate tennis courts.
Six be a teacher please,
please,
please be a teacher.
Teachers are the most admirable and
important people in the world.
You don't have to do it forever,
but if you're in doubt about what to do,
be an amazing teacher.
Even if you're not a teacher,
be a teacher.
Share your ideas.
Don't take for granted your education.
Rejoice in what you learn and spray it.
Seven,
define yourself by what you love.
I found myself doing this thing a bit
recently where if someone asks me what
sort of music I like,
I say,
well,
I don't listen to the radio because pop
song lyrics and Nymi or if someone asks
me what food I like I say,
I think truffle oil is overused and
slightly obnoxious and I see it all the
time online people whose idea of being
part of a subculture is to hate coldplay
or football or feminists or the Liberal
Party.
We have a tendency to define ourselves
in opposition to stuff.
As a comedian,
I make my living out of it,
but try to also express your passion for
things you love.
Be Demonstrative and generous in your
praise of those you admire.
Send thank you cards and give standing
ovations.
Be Pro stuff,
not just anti stuff.
Eight respect people with less power
than you.
I have in the past made important
decisions about people.
I work with agents and producers,
big decisions based largely on how they
treat the wait staff in the restaurants
we're having the meeting in.
I don't care if you're the most powerful
cat in the room.
I will judge you on how you treat the
least powerful.
So there nine,
finally,
don't rush.
You don't need to already know what
you're going to do with the rest of your
life.
Don't panic.
You will soon be dead.
Okay?
Life will sometimes seem long and tough
and God,
it's tiring and you will sometimes be
happy and sometimes sad,
and then you'll be old and then you'll
be dead.
There is only one sensible thing to do
with this empty existence and that is
fill it,
not fill it,
fill it.
Life is best filled by learning as much
as you can about as much as you can,
taking pride in whatever you're doing,
having compassion,
sharing ideas,
running,
being enthusiastic.
And then there's love and travel and
wine and sex and art and kids and giving
and mountain climbing.
But you know that stuff already.
It's an incredibly exciting thing.
This one meaningless life of yours.
Good luck and thank you for indulging
me.